*muffled* Doesn't make much sense to me!
But I'll g- I'll- I'll go do it.
Alright alright then.
AUGH! *Camera Click*
Wait, I wasn't ready!
*Chuckle* What did you do?
Did you take my picture?
Was that the official weigh-in?
I don'- (AUGH!)Woah, hey hey!
*Nervous laughter* Woah, hey Boris.
Hey, what are you doing?
Woah.
Uh, Hang on...
I need to do summin' quick. Can you stop staring at me like a freakin' weirdo?
My god, you got beautiful eyes.
You got ugly everything else, but beautiful eyes.
I got it! Beuff
Oh jeez, sorry about that Boris.
Boink! Oh my god you're angry!
BOOP BOOP BOOP BOOP BOOP BOOP
Bippity Bippity Bippity Bippity
Oh, give me a big kiss! *Exaggerated Smooch*
You're such a beautiful chubby cheek little bitch!
Oh look at you!
BOW!
UH BOINK
HUH BOOF!
boo- boof?
Oh, you got iron chest.
Everything else about you is as [giggles] weak as shit can be!
[giggles] You're such a loser! My trainer, more like my failure!
My failed creation! My failed son!
But you got a nice chest though.
Boink! *laughter* Boink!
Uh oh.
Man, lemme just get some o' dat titty there.
it looks like you're jerking him off...
[Giggles] Boinkety boinkety boinkety boinkety.  Who's... Who's *Laughs*
Who's a big boy?? Who's a big boy?!
Who's Boris the big boy??
I am! me am. me, me me me
i am being held in a basement by Markiplier forced to make subtitles for him
Did I just get turned around?
OOH I got turned around! Oh I'm sorry! I'm an idiot. Okay. Never mind
So, you're over there! I thought you were over there for some fucking reason I dunno why.
*sudden realization* Oh hey! How's it going?!
Ok, so you're over there...
You're right there!
Alright! so "An enemy on guard will block your swings."
Eh!
Ehh!
EH!
..Eh...
eh eh eh eh *sound of glass breaking*
Oh jeez my hands!
They call me Glass-Hands-Markiplier.
*bu dum tss*
Oh no.
*rapid inhales and exhales*AHH! OHH! Okay. [momentary Pause] AHHHHHH my haannddss!! *Glass Breaking*
*giggles* OOHH GOD I just told you I was Glass-Hands-Markiplier, why have you done this!?
Alright.
"Pulling your fists farther back will do more damage"
Well, look at this! I'm going to do the Sonic Windup©®℗™℠ on you bitch!
HAA BOWWSKY!
That didn't seem like... let me just-
WIND IT UP AGAIN??
*said wimpily* uh BOOUUHH
Oh shit.
*yells*BORIS! BORIS!
Ha, oh, he's fine. Ok Boris come on
Ha, oh, he's fine. ok boris come on
That's some weird lucha libre headgear you got goin on there
*burps* eeuughh
woah hey- buh BORIS. boris come on
Let's talk about this. I don't know where the edge of the map is.
Oh geez boris, come on, haaa, WOAH HO! HEY-EY! How did you? back up a little bit
*weakly* Hah, ah, bleh, weh,  ahh, AHH
*whines* I'm just giving you a bi- ohh jeez I just saw something I didn't wanna see Boris
*wimpy* Eh
*Another wimpy* Eh
*punches* Ooh ah ooh ooh  *sounds of glass breaking followed by a high feminine scream* I dodged you bitch!
*orgasm*
Oh! *sounds of glass breaking*
Heel- oh shit
Wha- whatchu gonna do, huh? Ya can't hit me
You can't hit what you can't see
Huh bitch? Huh? Whatcha gonna do? Huh?
OOAAH! AHHH!
ooh ah ooh
Uh oh
EAAH! ah uh UH OOH!
Ah shit, my glass hands
Whatcha gonna do huh? Whatcha gonna do huh? Whatcha gonna
WOOO!
Ok
Whatcha gonna do hu-
WOO!
Whatcha gonna do huh?
WOOOO!
BAM!
*mark killed a man*
ohhh, yeah!
fuck you oh don't get up don't don't hey
hey hey come on
*realization that the man has been resurrected*
don't get up! don't-- don't
hey hey
HEY COME ON!
I dont fight fair
[Whipmy] Eh
woahohoho
you're out for good, Boris.
don't even try to get back up!
WOOOOO!
Oh. Hey. [low toned] oh hey
No hard feelings, ay Boris?
ah....
we're cool?
ugly Joe nasato?
i'll take him
ah.. come on! come on! who they got?
I'm a-- oh hey. how's it going??
OH MAN! You really ARE ugly!
Oh Boy.
You got NO abs!
Nice grundle.
GOODNESS MARK
I like this. Let me fix your bow.
yeah. let me get this, I gotta i-ohh
*succ*
You like that? *Smooch*
How about a little bit of that. on the tip of your giant nose?
Oh
Float like a butterfly, kiss like a bee!
*Smooch*
Boink
oooh. UUAAHH my face!
Ah everything is getting dark!
hu, hu.. Huaah BOINK!
Boink...
oh shit
huagh.. boink
oohh
Huah, Sidewinder!
Ill throw a wicked haymaker!
no one tell "Michaell watson" on me
Whoop, Whoop! Whoah, whoah!
Wooo, WOOO!
Im the man! Look at me go.
whoo, eee, AHH!
*victory screech*
Oh, dont get up!
It's ok, don-dont get up for me.
Ah, not yet.
thank yo--waah
oah, ho, Agh!
I only dodge to the right.
eeh, eh
1-2 combo!
Wow, 1-2 combo!
Woah you're ugly! Ugly as shit bruh.
block
OOOOWWWW
block-aaooh
Block! Eh, eh eh!
Dodge, boink boink!
Dodge, *Glass Cracking* boink boink, *victory screech*
A-ha-ha
Ooh, OH
OH
Uuuh, uuuh
*followed by masturbation*
Get some, bitch!
ehh
ooh ooh oooh
Oh, shit! I knocked my headphones out!
Fuck, uuuhuh
Hang on, pause it Pause It Paus-Time Out!
Alright
Back in it.
Oh whoah, ha, haa?
wah, huh, what huh
Haa? Wha
what oh whoa about the boy
huh, oh, wah
[Drunkly] weeelllhoowboouutthiiis
Ha-boink
Touch
huh? oh oh yeah your face? BAH BAH BOW BOW BOW
Thought i had that. Though i had you
then wouldn't that mean you're abusing your own child; that's child abuse you'll go to jail; as you can tell by this text I am fucking triggered
oh
*three stooges imitation*
whoop whoop whoop [momentary pause] whoop whoop whoop whooo!
*bang*
ow! my lights... don't knock 'em out
euuhh uhhh uhhh
woah
euhh uuh
AHHH! God Damn it i did it again! Fuck! AHH TIME OUT!
[long ]ok... that's right one? I don't know
*Bang*
AHHHHH! My lights, why?
oh, I'm good thanks buddy okay here we go
ugly I don't remember what your name is
whoa whoa whoa
hope hope hope oh haha - ass and
Markiplier win
[cheering] HOHOOOH!!!!
Glass hands markiplier©®℗™℠ wins AGAAAAIIIIIN!
admittedly my first one was only against my
trainer but you get it you, get it
whooh
Oh jees high horrors
how you doin'
*giggles*
Alright
"ugly joe"
Wait Wheres some more?
what there's no more? what? But I beat
him I beat him fair and square what do I
got to beat him again
will you ever learn that child abuse is wrong
probably
nice good combo me thanks me I'm
really making my family proud
look by getting my brain beat out of me
Whoop
WAM! WAM!
Whoop!
WAM! WAM! WAM!
you and your face caved in but . .
Boink Boink
come on, come on, come on, come on, let's FUCK EM UP!
eughh
aghh
[releif] ahh fuck
there we go
Yeah
yea- what no don't get up
Don't get up don't you eeaaaghhh!
[Yells High Pitched] DONT DO THAT DONT GET UP
[Yells High Pitched] OOOAAAAHHHH!
ugh
Ngh
AUGH! jesums
eugh
c'mon, c'mon, c'mon, woah wh- Ahh!
My Lights!
Well you got yours!
female with just as much rights and wages as a man sexually identifying as a dog respectively!
bitch
Woo
[long and loud] Oh... Nellaayy
Im the winner
[releif] hoah
oh shit sorry did I hit you i'm sorry but
i love it
*Exaggerated smooch*I love you *Smooch* love you *smooch* love you *Smooch* Love you
boop boop boop
ok oh boy well it doesn't look like
there's any more opponents right now
woah shit where- how did i get over there
ok so it doesn't look like there's any
more opponents right now but I'm sure
beat the shit out of that guy, twice
HE WAS JUST A CHILD!
so that's all for [exhausted panting] the thrill of the
fight, im out of breath, im very sweaty
I might throw up, what do you think of that
maybe they're going to add more fighters
later but this is what I imagined when I
thought they were going to be a boxing
game and the vibe
pretty cool right so let me know what
you thought in the comments down below
alright still catching my breath but thanks
again everybody for watching, if you want
see more cool
five games ive done in the past it will be a
link in the description
thanks again for watching, and as always
i'll see you in the next video bye bye
[top video] OOOHH! YEESSS!
[bottom video] ooh ahh hi
whoops
wha-
hah
YEEAASSSSS!
It was an honor subtitling your videos, Mark. I'm a big fan of yours.